welcome to the man of recaps this is
fantastic beasts and where to find them
welcome back to the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter except about seventy years
before Harry was born
it's the Roaring Twenties and the Dark
Wizard of the day his Grindelwald
he's been wrecking havoc over in Europe
but in America things are pretty cool
meet Newt Scamander he's a nice British
lad crossing the pond with his trunk
full of magical creatures
he's an awkward kind of guy gets along
better with animals than with people
unfortunately it's a bad time for him to
come to New York with a suitcase full of
magical creatures because some
mysterious magical beast has been
wrecking havoc on the city one of newts
animals gets out and wrecked some minor
havoc of its own it's a platypus mole
that likes shiny things so Newt has to
chase him into a bank inside he meets
Jacob Kowalski a nomad which is what
they call muggles in America he's here
to get a loan to open a bakery but Newt
has no time for small talk he's got a
chases platypus mole unfortunately Newt
drops an egg so Jacob so I guess I'll
take this for now he goes to the loan
meeting hey I've got a great idea I'm
gonna make donuts and we can dunk them
in coffee dunking doughnuts that's a
terrible idea loon rejected when he gets
out the egg starts to hatch sown it's
like come on over here buddy and bill
they have some sort of chicken snake
together long story short Newt gets the
platypus mole back and warps them out of
there he's like old still mate I'm gonna
just erase your memory then but Jacobs
like I don't think so and he runs away
so as newts leaving there's a girl
coming down and they're both so awkward
they won't make eye contact and their
awkwardness explodes oh now she's a
witch - and she warps him out of there
she's like my name's Tina I'm with the
magical NYPD you're under arrest for a
magical creature havoc so she brings him
in to see her boss super sexy Colin
Farrell luckily he and Jacob
accidentally switched suitcases so mutes
free to go but Jacob is having a rough
time back home and a bunch of the
magical beasts escape Newton Tina get
over there and put the Koosh ball Pig
back but Jake got bit so they take him
back to her place for observation where
she's got a hot younger sister Queenie
and it is love at first sight that night
Newt goes down into his suitcase and
he's got a whole bunch of magical
creatures there there's the boulder
Beatles and Cthulhu horse there's birdy
snakes and leafy green stick men but
most special of all is the Thunder
chicken that's why nuke came to America
he rescued this guy from poachers or
whatever and is trying to put him back
in his native land of
but first Newt has to sneak out to find
all his missing creatures one of them is
a giant hippo Rhino who's in heat so
Newt has to do a crazy mating dance to
learn it back in unfortunately Jacob got
the musk on him and turns into a whole
chase scene but in the end Newt gets
back meanwhile this super annoying chick
leads the New Salem anti magic League
she's got this creepy looking son who's
been meeting secretly with sexy Colin
Farrell see she runs a little orphanage
and Colin Farrel thinks that one of them
is secretly a wizard he wants to know
which one and in exchange he promises to
teach this kid magic which he really
wants because his mom beats him and
generally sucks
one day she takes the whole family to
see newspaper guy in order to print an
anti-magic story but they kick him out
of there and his son in particular is
super mean to them
newspaper son is actually a New York
senator and that night boom boom shadow
monster busts in there oh and it kills
him meanwhile the girls realized Newt is
gone so Tina goes and grabs him she
brings him in for the misdemeanor of
magical creatures on the loose not
realizing that a New York senator was
just killed by one so they're all very
much under arrest
newts like I'm 8 my creatures aren't
dangerous none of them could have known
that but sexy Colin Farrell's like what
about this creepy shadow blob yeah that
could have done it that creature is an
obscurus it's a shadow monster created
when a young wizard represses their
magic so it bursts out in this form this
ones harmless though because
unfortunately it's child died but Newt
managed to trap it and is studying it
sexy Colin Farrell doesn't believe him
though he thinks they're working with
Grindelwald and apparently he has the
power to sentenced them to death no
trial needed for the death penalty and
magical America they pull out your fond
memories and throw them in the
euthanasia pool so you want to jump in
luckily newt has a leafy stickman on him
to pick the lock and he's also got a
quarter machine elastic sticky ball
which transforms into a kite bird and
saves the day they break the spell but
Tina's trap so he pulls in Aladdin do
you trust me and she jumps on the magic
carpet they're saved and they find
sister and Jacob and they're out of
there they gotta track down the rest of
newts missing animals to clear their
names so they go to a speakeasy and talk
to Goblin makjang stir face he tells him
about some invisible creature living in
macy's turns out it's newts shaggy et
monkey and also a giant bird snake this
thing grows to fit its container so they
find a little teapot and a
Roach in the teapot Putin bird snake
goes in there nice and small now and all
the magical creatures are home safe now
creepy ladies got a daughter who was
playing with a fake wand so it's time
for her beating but who the belt out of
her hand what little girl's a witch and
wholly obscure his attacks and kills
creepy lady so creepy kid tells sexy
Collin the witch is probably his little
sister and Collin Farrel betrays him I
was never gonna teach you magic user
but when Colin Farrell finds the sister
surprise twist the brother was the
wizard all along and he's the obscurus
now he's mad and he's unleashed upon New
York surprise Colin Farrell's the bad
guy he wants to use the obscurus for his
own ends so Tina comes in to distract
him while Nick goes and tries to talk
the kid down they fly down into the
subway and obscurus is going crazy
eventually Tina manages to calm him down
a bit but then all the other magic cops
show up and decide to shoot first and
ask questions later so boom the obscurus
is dead and unfortunately they killed
that kid with it they're like hey it's a
tragedy but we had to do it to keep the
Wizarding World a secret but Colin
Farrell's like maybe we shouldn't keep
it a secret
we should rise up and conquer the
muggles uh what so they start fighting
but he's way stronger than any of them
but he's not stronger than sticky ball
kite bird manages to tie him up and
turns out he's not just working with
Grindelwald
he is Grindelwald and he's not just
Colin Farrell he's Johnny Depp I'm the
dude playing the dude but didn't to beat
the other dude
so Grindelwald going to jail you can bet
he's breaking out for the sequel though
and unfortunately the muggles saw
everything so there's no way to erase
that many memories but wait newts got an
idea it's time for the Thunder chicken
he's got a vial of forgetty juice and
thunder chicken can make it rain so it's
amnesia rain all the muggles like wait
what do we do it here so the whole event
is covered up and the day is saved not
by a powerful wizard but by an awkward
kid with a trunk full of weird animals
unfortunately poor Jacobs gotta wipe his
memory too but not before he gets a kiss
with Goldie and what about Newton Tina
have they had a romance arc to be honest
not really they're probably better off
as friends and it still carries the
picture of his ex-girlfriend
Lidl estranged relative of the evil
Bellatrix Lestrange from the originals
will this come up in the sequel probably
but the moment feels right so newt
decides to go for an awkward Casablanca
here's looking at you kid
Oh at least were both so awkward maybe
they should be together and before he
leaves me bumps into Jacob gives him a
bunch of silver eggs so he could start
his bakery he ditches the Dunkin Donuts
idea though makes fantastical beast
pastries instead but one day Goldy stops
by and it's love at Second Sight and
that's how fantastic beasts comes to an
end
[Music]